o Imagine
e você com seus filhos
e com seu pai com a sua mãe que seus
avós
e seus netos
você no lugar bacana onde é tudo teu
já imaginou
E aí de repente chega um pessoas que
você nunca viu
o que essas pessoas simplesmente
o pegam seus filhos sua esposa a sua mãe
E aí levo embora
e foi isso o que aconteceu
e fecha seus olhos
o
Imagine você dentro de um navio
e com pouca roupa
e no espaço apertado
é um espaço que você
e faz as suas necessidades fisiológicas
eu sendo homem e mulher crianças
eu e você nesse navio no calor
e sem ter acesso a nada
a e nesse trajeto
Há muitos não resistem e morrem
e passam a ser
os alimentos de peixes imaginou
e esta é a realidade
o que foi feito com os meus ancestrais
e foi desse jeito
é com esse Requinte de crueldade
e a diáspora
e
deixou marcas profunda nas estruturas do
mundo
ó e aqui no Brasil não é diferente pois
quem somos
é a segunda maior população de negros
fora do continente africano
E além disso o Brasil foi o último país
e a reconhecer
e a escravidão extinta
em todas as ações
provocam até nos dias de hoje
as Profundas desigualdades
O que são essas desigualdades que
precisam ser corrigidas
e eu aprendi com os meus pais que os
meus avós os mais velhos que
nós precisamos renunciar o nosso eu
bom e nos vestir
do todo do coletivo
é a minha transformação aconteceu
e no ano de 1987
o ano este que
só eu sobrevivi
um ano esse que meu irmão e alguns
amigos não conseguiram sobreviver
Oi e eu vi a minha mãe e outras Mães
tá chorando a perda de um filho
de decidir então ou resolver
traçar um plano na minha vida
o e continuar sonhando
é mas
e para realizar esses sonhos
e é importante que outras pessoas saem
juntos
e a partir dessa data
e eu comecei acreditar finalmente
a educação é uma ferramenta de
transformação
e não mas como transformar como que
aquele jovem nascido numa periferia
da grande São Paulo conseguiria
implementar tantas coisas para mudar
vidas
e a receita foi buscar outras pessoas
o que junto com você
renunciar um eu
o vídeo uma maneira horizontal
iniciou uma grande gestão
O que é educação
O Popular participativa
o E acima de tudo anti-racista
a construir uma algumas coisas
extremamente significante
o começo Dandara
o evento este que
e empodera
e as mulheres em especial as
afrodescendente
é através de três tópicos
a autoestima
a economia criativa
e respeito à ancestralidade
no mês Dandara não tem disputa
é omisso Dandara se cria vínculos
bom você criar redes
o Luiz Dandara
as pessoas que chegam
e ela sai amigas ela sai fortalecido das
ela sai empoderados
o E acima de tudo ela sai transformadas
e se despindo doeu
É esse mesmo coletivo
e construiu também uma ultrassom os
cursinhos populares
cursinhos populares que vai no mais
extremo da cidade
a buscar aquele aluno
O que que tem uma inteligência mas não
tenho condição Econômica
bom e nós proporcionamos
e é esse jovem a esta jovem a
oportunidade
o e aprofundar os estudos
é tudo gratuito
professores todos gratuitos
não cobra nada para dar aula
e orientadores pedagógicos
psicólogos assistente social
a todos unidos um único objetivo
fazer com que
e esse jovem que não tinha um sonho
passa a se alimentar e ter um sonho
Oi e o cursinho Popular que nós
realizamos a anos
à venda no resultado mas nós queremos
avançar ainda mais
hoje nós queremos chegar em todos os
cantos do Brasil
o nosso cursinho Popular gratuito
e eu não consigo fazer isso
sozinho preciso de outras pessoas porque
eu acredito na força do coletivo
na força da gestão
horizontal o de todos têm o direito da
fala
respeitando aquilo que é básico
que seguindo a ética a honestidade
e acima de tudo os princípios
e o respeito à diferença
os nossos cursinhos aposta nessas
narrativas
nessa educação o que
preza pela extinção daquilo que hoje é
considerado o mal do século
o preconceito a discriminação
EA intolerância
nós formamos jovens para serem técnicos
acreditamos na inovação Mas acima de
tudo
buscamos formar
pessoas emanada pela paz
é pela pelo pela vontade de multiplicar
e os nossos cursinhos
é uma ultrassom e nós buscamos e que é
extremamente
importante Dizer para vocês
Essa é a superação
e nós acreditamos da superação
a superar Imagine você um pai com seu
filho
comprando um par de tênis e você
passando por um constrangimento
de ser confundido por pessoas que fazem
coisas não tão numa normais
aconteceu isso comigo
é e nem um momento eu me abate
é porque eu tive uma base sólida
é desse instante
nós já resolvemos
formar jovens para
combater através da Educação
e a discriminação racial o olhar
invernizado
nós vivemos numa sociedade aonde
77 por cento da juventude que morre por
resultado nesses longos 350 anos
é desse regime Que escravizou pessoas
são jovens negros e nós queremos
reverter isso através de oportunidade
atravessa da educação e acima de tudo
compartilhando as boas novas
e é nisso que nós acreditamos
se você viver
e para você talvez não seja
algo difícil
e agora o importante é você ter a
empatia é você olhar o teu vizinho
bom e você perceber que você estando
sozinho
e é muito pior do que quando você está
e em parcerias
o que nós acreditamos cegamente
na gestão das parcerias
Ah pois ninguém faz nada sozinho o que
me trouxe aqui hoje
o estágio Tec visita
e foi o resultado
de ações coletiva
e quem está aqui é Claudinei Correia mas
estou aqui representando milhares de
pessoas que acreditaram naquele sonho
daquele menino lá em 1987
o que saiu lá do vídeo Holanda na cidade
de Osasco eu estou aqui hoje são por
esses e queremos e muito mais longe
queremos deixar um legado para outros
que virão continuar
nós queremos que as pessoas entendam Que
importante ser aquele beija-flor
é que quando a floresta está incêndio
ele vai com seu biquinho da água jogando
água mas e aí não apagou incêndio
mas ele fez a sua parte e se todos e
todas as pessoas fizeram mínimo nós
teremos um país mais justo
e mais igualitário
e mais feliz
e nós acreditamos essa felicidade isso
tem nome cultura de paz
Oi e essa cultura de paz precisa ser
plantada em todos os lugares em todos os
cantos do Norte a Sul de Leste a oeste
e nós precisamos aprender a nos
respeitar
indiferente e qual seja sua cor de pele
de qual for o seu time de futebol
na prisão viver em espírito de unidade
assim nós iremos eliminar todas as
formas de desigualdades existentes em
nosso país que foram construídas e tudo
o que é construído precisa ser
reconstruído para o melhor
E durante e nesses últimos dois anos
e
nessa pandemia
e Nós não paramos
e nós continuamos a trabalhar
e por isso a importância da Inovação
e continuamos a trabalhar levar o nosso
apoio às pessoas que precisam
e Nós criamos campanhas solidárias de
arrecadação de alimentos
onde pessoas minimamente possa ter o o
arroz e feijão em sua mesa
hoje nós queremos campanhas de
distribuição de máscaras de álcool gel
hoje nós queremos até mesmo
uma
plataforma online aonde
Se as pessoas
pudessem estudar à distância
tudo isso feito pelo coletivo
e tudo isso feito em nome de uma única
palavra
a empatia
bom E nós queremos chegar muito mais
longe ainda
bom e nós precisamos de outras mãos de
outras pernas porque o sonho quando você
sonha sozinho é só um sonho
é mas quando você
renuncia seu sonho e coloca outros
sonhos em sua realidade se tornar
realidade
bom e é isto que eu estou fazendo aqui
no teu deck Zita
se tornando sonhos em realidade
e é extremamente importante dialogarmos
é sobre
e três prefeitos
a consciência
a equidade
a
respeito
nós precisamos ter consciência que
vivemos em uma sociedade desigual
Oi e essa desigualdade
continua fazendo muitas mães sofrerem
e não adianta ter acesso um carro de
primeira linha se eu não posso andar com
meu carro com vidro aberto
é porque outras pessoas
e por vários motivos
e não tiveram essa mesma oportunidade E
aí nós estamos falando de valores
históricos e quando nós falamos em
valores históricos
e nós precisamos citar
e os privilégios históricos que algumas
pessoas tiveram
e em detrimento de outras pessoas
E aí está
é a grande emblemática brasileira
nós não queremos atacar ninguém nem
iremos atacar as pessoas nós queremos
unir as pessoas para ter esse
entendimento se estiver bem para todo
mundo
E aí não teremos problemas é só isso
nós falamos a consciência agora tudo
isso é possível quando nós colocamos em
prática a e o idade
se é para tar com o diferença os
diferentes E aí cuidad ela proporciona
você tratar
aquele que não teve a mesma oportunidade
e maneiras diferentes e aí você nem vela
as oportunidades e quando você me ver as
oportunidades o resultado vem
E é isso que nós fazemos
mas nós fazemos bem pequenininho e
queremos fazer muito grande e para fazer
maior
precisamos de vocês
Ah e por fim
a utilizar dessas ferramentas da
tecnologia
a Inovar
da Inovação
e nós acreditamos que através da
Inovação nós podemos chegar mais longe
a adentrarem tantos lares
bom e fazer a transformação
essa transformação é possível eu sou
Claudinei Correia
bom e foi transformado estou aqui para
contar para vocês
bom obrigado